♪♪♪
♪ Oh Oh Oooooh ♪
♪ Oh Oh Ooooooh ♪
♪ A chaques fois ♪
♪ Que je te vois  ♪
♪ Nos regards se croisent et je me noie ♪
♪ Ta douceur ♪
♪ Ma douleur ♪
♪ Quand t'approches un autre gars que moi ♪
♪ J'vais tout donner ♪
♪ T'es ma beauté ♪
♪ On va s'évader ♪
♪ Tu m'as hypnotisé ♪
♪ Ça va le faire ♪
♪ J'cale l'affaire ♪
♪ L'étau se resserre ♪
♪ Je sens la chaleur monter heyyyyy ♪
♪ J'ai attendu si longtemps ♪
♪ Ce soir c'est notre moment ♪
♪ C'est juste toi et moi babe ♪
♪ Mais je te dis bye bye si tu fais du sale ♪
♪ Oh Oh Oooooh ♪
♪ Je rêve de toi, je ne pense qu'à toi ♪
♪ Et mon cœur fait ♪
♪ Ooooh Oh Oh ♪
♪ Je rêve de toi, je ne pense qu'à toi ♪
♪ Mais je te dis bye bye ♪
♪ Bye bye ♪
♪ Bye bye si tu fais du sale, j'te dis bye bye ♪
♪ Bye bye si tu fais du sale ♪
♪ J'perds le contrôle ♪
♪ Quand nos corps se frôlent ♪
♪ Quand tu bouges en rythme ♪
♪ Quand tu me donnes envie ♪
♪ C'est toi la reine ♪
♪ J'vais pas hésiter ♪
♪ J'peux pas résister ♪
♪ J'peux pas t'éviter ♪
♪ Ils tournent tous autour de toi mais c'est moi que tu veux ♪
♪ Cette soirée on sait qu'on va la finir à deux ♪
♪ Ils veulent tous te faire danser mais tu t'en moques d'eux ♪
♪ Arrêtons d'faire semblant faut qu'on passe aux aveux ♪
♪ J'ai attendu si longtemps ♪
♪ Ce soir c'est notre moment ♪
♪ C'est juste toi et moi babe ♪
♪ Mais je te dis bye bye si tu fais du sale ♪
♪ Ooooh Ooh Oh ♪
♪ Je rêve de toi, je ne pense qu'à toi ♪
♪ Et mon cœur fait ♪
♪ Ooooh Ooh Oh ♪
♪ Je rêve de toi, je ne pense qu'à toi ♪
♪ Mais je te dis bye bye ♪
♪ Bye bye ♪
♪ Bye bye si tu fais du sale, j'te dis bye bye ♪
♪ Bye bye si tu fais du sale ♪
♪ Je ferais trop le lover ♪
♪ On kiffera jusqu'à pas d'heures ♪
♪ Tu m'as touché en plein cœur ♪
♪ J'aime quand tu suis la vibe ♪
♪ Girl ♪
♪ Quand tu suis la vibe ♪
♪ La vibe ♪
♪ Girl ♪
♪ Oooh Ooh Oh ♪
♪ Je rêve de toi, je ne pense qu'à toi ♪
♪ Et mon cœur fait ♪
♪ Oh Oh Oh ♪
♪ Je rêve de toi, je ne pense qu'à toi ♪
♪ Mais je te dis bye bye ♪
♪ Bye bye ♪
♪ Bye bye si tu fais du sale, j'te dis bye bye ♪
♪ Bye bye si tu fais du sale ♪
♪ Oooh Ooh Oh ♪
♪ Ooooh Ooh Oh ♪